Hoda copy has been noticeably absent
from The Today Show for more than a week
prompting fans to ask where is she
sometimes you wonder like should I share
this or should I not the answer is
always yes meanwhile Savannah Guthrie
left mid-show on Tuesday after testing
positive for covid Savannah left early
she wasn't feeling great so she took a
covet test it came back positive so of
course as soon as we found out she
rushed home to rest up so Savannah we
love you first let's talk Hoda the
Anchor's last live appearance on the
show was February 17th yay for Friday
and yay for this long holiday weekend
it's arriving right on time World News
Tonight anchor Tom yamas and today third
hour co-host Craig Melvin have been
subbing for Hoda over the last week
alongside Savannah meanwhile Willie
Geist from Sunday today and Chanel Jones
of today third hour have filled in
alongside Jenna Bush Hager for Hoda's
fourth hour gig but still no official
announcement or explanation of where
Hoda is
ET has reached out for comment Whitley
Geist is in for Hoda good to see you
again you know what I'm happy we are
here this is great also worth noting
Hoda's today Channel podcast making
space which normally releases shows
every Monday has also not dropped a new
episode since February 20th neither
Savannah nor Jenna have revealed any
specific details about Hoda's absence
and while Hoda hasn't been on the show
she has been on social media posting
some inspirational quotes and messages
on her Instagram which is business as
usual for the mom of two earlier this
week Hoda shared this image with the
quote choose hope some days I feel
powerful most things I feel vulnerable
but Hoda isn't the only co-anchor absent
from The Today Show on Tuesday Savannah
left mid-show after testing positive for
covid-19 Savannah left early she wasn't
feeling great so she took a covet test
it came back positive so of course as
soon as we found out she rushed home to
rest up so Savannah we love you wishing
you a speeding
yeah well Chanel was sitting between me
and uh
this marks the third time Savannah has
tested positive for covet the anchor got
a positive result in May 2022 forcing
her to stay home and Miss five days of
the broadcast before that she tested
positive in January 2022. we know how
blessed we are we know how lucky we are
as for Hoda E.T was with her longtime
pal and colleague Savannah earlier this
month who made it clear she's a big Hoda
fan I mean Hoda at the top of the list
always she she's an icon I mean she
absolutely is just one of just a rock to
me and to all of us every single day
[Music]
thank you